what's going on everybody welcome to a
new tutorial which is also kind of part
1 in a little miniseries but really all
we're going to be doing in this tutorial
is doing and kind of working through a
couple of sentiment analysis libraries
that are just kind of out of the box
libraries you can download and perform
sentiment analysis with we're gonna kind
of check them both out see what they
have to offer us and see which one we
want to go with if there's some other
sentiment analysis library or curious
about testing you can go through the
same exact methodology to analyze them
and see and see what you think so the
two that we're going to use our text
blob and Vader sentiment you can just
pip install a text blog Vader sentiment
text blob is a natural image processing
library built on top of NLT K whereas
Vader sentiment so basically text block
can do more than just on an analysis an
invader sentiment it's just sentiment
analysis if you're curious about both of
these you can learn more about them if
you go to the description I link to the
text base tutorial there and you can you
can check them out here and here so what
I want to do is just just get to working
with them and test test them against
known data so the known data I'm going
to use is this these like movie reviews
and I've got a positive and a negative
file if I recall to do it I'll put just
straight links to them in the
description otherwise just go to the
text-based version and just and find
them and download them or you can use
your own data if you have your own but
anyways these are just like short movie
reviews so you can just right click
download save as these reviews and we're
going to use them for classification so
the first thing I'm going to do is I'm
just going to go ahead and drag those
over cool and now we can actually we can
test both of these using this and I like
this data set because they're kind of
challenging they're not necessarily
always clear some of them are very
sarcastic some of them are like just
plain confusing like I couldn't have
classified them so it's a nice confusing
set a real challenge to feed to a
classifier so it's still interesting to
see how well can it do and not just how
well can it do on
like the whole set but is it good at
filtering out the things that it doesn't
know so there with a lot of classifiers
a benefit that you can have sometimes is
that the classifier itself can determine
what's kind of confidence level is when
it makes a classification so if you can
do that it would be nice to be able to
go through these these two files here
and on the really challenging ones that
it you know is it good at at least
recognizing I'd just I don't know the
answer but I'll make a guess kind of
stuff like that so anyways we're gonna
see what we can find with both of these
so the first one I'm going to start with
is going to be text blobs so we've
already got text blob imported and I'm
just gonna say the analysis equals text
blob and all you do is you're just gonna
pass a string to this so I'm just gonna
say text blob sure looks like it has
some interesting features and and that's
it so what that's going to do is just
convert this into a text blob object and
we can do all kinds of things with the
text blob object so what one thing we
can do to figure out all the things we
can do is just derp it and let me just
make some more space here that's the
zoom out so obviously we have all the
little done ders here but we can also
see all kinds of stuff like polarity and
sentiment which we're interested in we
can see we would canto kanai's it we can
do word counts we can even translate it
part of speech all that kind of stuff so
there's definitely a lot of things that
we have at our disposal so one thing I
thought that was pretty cool is is the
translation so one option we have is
just a print analysis translate and then
you put the language code in here so two
equals and let's do Spanish so es and
we'll run that and here you go this has
been translated to Spanish I'm not gonna
read that out but that's pretty cool I
don't know how great of a translation is
Spanish isn't exactly a language of mine
I can sort of speak it but yeah so it
looks about right it seems like a pretty
dirty translation
but anyways that's kind of cool they you
could do stuff like that so it's more
than just sentiment that we can do but
the other thing we can do for example
would be part of speech tags so we can
just do analysis tags and in fact let me
just get rid of the dirt there we can
run that and then then we get all these
tags and just going from the text-based
version of this charlie just bring it
over but I have all the tags in the
text-based version of the tutorial so
check that out if you want to know all
of the tags because there's quite a few
one reason you'd want to know this is
for things like if you want to build
noun phrases but also if you want to
know what's what's being talked about
here look for the the proper nouns
basically so in this case text blob is
being determined to be that proper noun
and then you can find the other nouns
too and then say okay there's let's say
positives let's say if this was positive
sentiment we we could relatively well
determine that there's positive
sentiment for text blob but why text
blob well because of the features there
are interesting features right so you
can start to do a lot of really cool
analysis but anyway this is for
sentiment so let's go ahead and just do
analysis dot sentiment and let's run
that and we see we get two scores we
have polarity and subjectivity so I want
to make sure I'm right on this but I'm
the polarity I believe is negative one
to positive one so negative one being
you know negative sentiment positive one
being positive sentiment and then
subjectivity is a degree from zero to
one where zero is very objective and
then one is very subjective I'm not
finding here I'm pretty sure that's
about correct though so now what I want
us to go ahead and do is we can we can
test these things so the the code that
I've written to do that is very simple
code so I'm actually just gonna copy it
from the the text-based tutorial I don't
really see any value of us writing this
this out I'll just kind of explain it so
so from that sentiment when we say
analysis sentiment we see it produces
this value and then we can access these
two attributes just using dot notation
basically so so we're saying dot
polarity to
to reference this number that's that
sentiment number okay and then all we're
doing is we're just opening these files
reading through and then if the polarity
is above is above zero we're saying okay
that should be positive if we got that
right add one to correct because this is
the positive file so everything should
be positive here otherwise if even if we
got it wrong we just pause count plus
equals one and then we're going to do
this one and then here we just calculate
the percentage accuracy so let's go
ahead and run that real quick we've
brewed should be relatively quick there
we go okay so in this case I got a
positive accuracy as seventy one percent
which is not horrible
but then the negative accuracy is fifty
five percent which it's above average
but on a sample size this small we can't
actually make that determination yet
probably but also even if it was a solid
fifty-five that's a little too close to
two random for my tastes so what are
some things that we could do well when
you could start to try to play with you
know where is where's the line for
neutral like a neutral zone so so rather
than saying is above zero what if we
said it needs to be above zero point two
right or below zero point two like it
looks like maybe we're too weighted
towards the positive so you could start
to play it with stuff like that to try
to get them both to be relatively equal
but as we can see even with that tiny
tweak now it's heavily weighted towards
negative so then what you know you can
continue tweaking it but we're clearly
not really seemingly making any gains
here by raising that bar so yeah so in
this case sixty and sixty eight really
neither of those and nowhere in between
those would be a number I would be happy
about doing sentiment analysis with any
serious degree so the next thing that we
could do is we could take subjectivity
into account so let's return this back
to zero
and
we could ask the question about
subjectivity so I'm just gonna copy and
paste this line and I'm gonna say right
if the subjectivity it needs to be less
than 0.3 so we want to be close to
objectivity right so that's what we're
gonna do and then we're just gonna throw
out the other ones just to see is there
is there a way that we could gather
sentiment at least on things that we
know we're correct on so let's go ahead
and run that one and see what we get so
it looks like negative accuracy goes up
significantly although our sample size
has been seriously you know diminished
like almost like a fifth and then the
other option we could do is raise it
like what if we maybe let's see if we
can get more subjective which to me
would seem to suggest that that would be
more dangerous right the more subjective
it is the less accurate we could
possibly be so we do get at least more
samples or I'm sorry whoops what I meant
to do is say let's say it needs to be
greater than 0.8 that's why we got more
samples okay running it again wait for
it
okay so this time we did kind of better
I guess which is odd like clearly it
looks like we don't want to necessarily
be too close to subjective or too close
to objective I don't really know I'm
having a hard time understanding how
we're supposed to value subjectivity
either way though we're simply not
getting enough samples so I just I don't
see how this is gonna be of any use so
at least so far in my opinion it's
getting kind of challenging to give any
sort of real value to here so so the
next thing after we've we've run through
text blob why not run Vader sentiment
instead so with Vader sentiment it's
going to be we're gonna build this
relatively similarly let me see if I can
just take it so that with Vader
sentiment we do have like a little
analysis bar otherwise most of this
stays the same but I'm
just copy and paste it paste and we
don't need this twice so here we just
define our analyzer right and then to do
sentiment you know because we're kind of
skipping the little phrase of our own
but basically to do sentiment to do
basic sentiment with Vader sentiment it
would be something like this I'll just
copy it over right so V s equals
analyzer dot polarity scores Vader
sentiment looks interesting I have high
hopes and then we could print out that
sentiment so let me go ahead and do that
just so you understand what to expect
from this package so when we run this
what we get is we get negative sentiment
neutral sentiment and positive sentiment
and then we have this sort of compound
score now if we read as which one's the
Vader yeah here we go if we read Vader
sentiment it should somewhere on here
tell us what these each of these here we
go so positive sentiment is just where
the comp I'm sorry uh let's see so about
the scoring basically what they're
saying here is the compound score is is
your most useful metric if you just
wanted a single metric to measure
sentiment but obviously we have quite a
few other things so like for example the
compound score is a combination of these
things
but it might be useful because in this
case this looks pretty clear right we
only have positive and neutral sentiment
there's really no negative sentiment
muddying up the waters so we could
probably be more confident in this
compound sentiment right so so even
though we could use compound and we'll
test compound it looks like we have a
few more things at our disposal that can
kind of help us detect when something
isn't quite right so so anyway let me go
ahead and clear this out analyze her
sentiment cool cool cool cool okay I
think we're all set let me just get rid
of this down here and so this is the
code I wrote for doing Vader sentiment
so basically it's going to be exactly
the same as what we've been working
with text blobs so we're just asking
with vs compound which is what they said
is the good single metric to work with
if it's greater than zero
congratulations you got positive right
if it's less than or equal to zero then
that's a negative and so on so now let's
go ahead and run this script and we get
something a little less strangely
weighted towards one way or the other
but still not really acceptable not
something that I would want to
personally go off of so 6957 is just not
that great but if we check the the
documentation here it basically says you
know you really should say anything
between negative zero point 5 and
positive zero point 5 we should call
that neutral and then if the positive
sentiment you know positive sentiment
would be above zero point 5 and the
negative sentiment would be less than
negative zero point five so let's go
ahead and try that out again I've
already written it out but it would be
some simple changes anyways but it'll be
quicker for me just to copy-paste here
it's double import and now and in fact
I'm gonna go ahead and just comment out
the library that we're not using that
seems to make sense so what I've done
here is I've built a threshold variable
and then basically what we're gonna ask
is if the compound is greater than or
equal to our threshold requirement or is
less than or equal to the negative of
the threshold requirement then we're
gonna use it otherwise if it doesn't
meet that threshold we don't care about
it we're gonna toss that data out so
let's go oh no what have I done I just
wanted to run that I think it ran I
don't know it like copied it over let me
just write it one more time
cool so in this case we get 87 percent
accuracy for positive and then 50% for
negative now that's pretty good but what
if we have another requirement or just
simply
a requirement that we don't want any
positive or negative sentiments so so
this was basically the this was the
suggestion of vape sentiment it was you
know hey use you know negative 0.5 to
positive point 5 as kind of your
threshold and honestly this is about I
mean 50 percent on negative is horrible
and then and also we talked aways tons
of our samples so so that's not good so
so now what I want to try is what if we
just ignore compound and instead we work
with the you know requiring the you know
basically the positive let's say out for
negative sentiment we want to have more
more negative than positive but then we
also don't want much positive if any so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
copy over a script that does basically
that again all this is in the text-based
version I'm just kind of running through
the methodology I use to go through
these two so paste that one in so
basically what we're going to do here is
if neg if the negative findings are not
more than 0.1 okay and then if the
positive minus the negative is still
greater than zero or greater than or
equal to zero
we're going to say positive is correct
and then we're going to come down here
with negative and we're gonna say okay
if if if the positive is not greater
than point 1 and positive minus negative
is not less than or equal to zero then
we're gonna say the negative is correct
as well so let's go ahead and run that
one and we can see we've done much much
better now one problem I see with this
immediately is both of these like in
theory you might have things that are
both being classified as positive and
negative because we're using the equals
so let me let me just test this real
quick so I don't really think about that
as I was going through it so yeah so
that we can see there makes a massive
difference if you're still allowing for
that
that are equal to so we can we can flip
the other one around but I'm going to be
relatively confident we're gonna see the
exact same issue here luckily this isn't
where it's actually not so so at least
in this case we can go with with greater
than zero for the positive requirement
or less than or equal to zero for the
negative requirement okay good enough
off to update the tutorial to to reflect
that one but you want to want to
continue making making those mistakes
now once we're willing to do this one
thing that we didn't really we didn't
give text blob the ability to to be
tested against you know zero like so so
we didn't give text blob all we did was
test text text blob with a moving center
point but never a neutral zone so the
next thing I want to do is go ahead and
let's test text blob in a neutral zone
so I'm going to copy this paste this in
so now we're going to test text blob the
polarity needs to be greater than or
equal to 0.5 or down here we could be
less than or equal to negative 0.5 but
in the polarity requirement 1 is greater
than 0 1 is less than or equal to 0 so
we've got no overlap going on there like
we had temporarily and the other one
let's go ahead and run that one okay so
in this one we have a hundred percent
accuracy
interestingly enough though not many
samples so what if we lower the the
threshold requirement so let's just do
like 0.2 for example let's run that one
okay so now we got many many more
samples but still we're losing quite a
few samples let me try one more we'll
just go to 0.1 see how many more we
gained here so we gained quite a few
especially in the positive negative is
still chopping away quite a few but
let's try this
those aren't even even there we go right
at one more time okay
still 100% accuracy so interestingly
enough in this one the real kicker is
the stupid zero like it looks like we
classify with text blob at least a lot
of things as zero zero sentiment
polarity which is causing a lot of
problems and that's why that less than
or equal to was making such a big
difference when we moved it around
especially for text blob less so for
vader sentiment it appeared but why that
made such a massive difference here but
as you can see with these rules we're
doing pretty well and clearly it's just
it was because of zeroes so so that's
basically the the two sentiment analysis
libraries compared it looks to me like
text blob is slightly better but the
other thing I didn't really talk about
is the speed so text blob right now is
taking me about six point seven seconds
to run through these two files which is
a little over 10,000 samples in total
yeah so solid six point seven seconds
and let me find a decent version of
let's do this one
of the vader sentiment copy/paste and
we'll run the vader sentiment example
this one runs in 3.3 seconds now this
one don't forget though is the one where
we have to be careful with the less than
or equal to zero we don't have any
overlap so that's a little more fair of
an assessment now we could also you know
we can probably continue tweaking this
one as well and we might find the same
it the same story with either one I
think that probably text blob is
slightly more accurate but Vader
sentiment seems to go you know twice
twice the speed so it's really just
gonna kind of depend on on what your
needs are but it looks to me like as
long as we're avoiding that zero mark
and properly classifying that or having
a neutral classification
it looks like text blob is is superior
also I'm kind of interested in text blob
just for doing other things besides just
doing you know sentiment maybe you want
to do part of speech classification or
whatever but I'm planning to use this
within putting into a database so that's
why I'm I haven't really decided which
one I want to use for this and honestly
they're very interchangeable as you've
seen we just need to figure out what
rules we want to go off of to make our
classifications but anyways that is all
for now if you have questions comments
concerns whatever you can feel free to
leave them below otherwise I'll see you
in the next tutorial